Traductor: María González Durán
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Bueno, cuando a uno le llaman
para dar una charla TED
se activan todos
los receptores del cerebro.
Todos.
Quieres una charla innovadora,
emocionante, que nunca hayas contado.
Quieres una charla que deje
un mensaje claro.
Que llegue al público.
Que haga que se levante.
Yo para empezar, tengo que deciros
que solo puedo defraudaros.
El listón está muy alto y es muy difícil
llegar hasta ahí.
Porque al fin y al cabo, no soy más que
un tipo normal.
Seguramente como
todos los que estáis aquí.
Vengo a contaros una historia
que es un tanto difícil.
Es un tanto complicada de armar.
Porque no vengo a hablaros de lo habitual.
De lo que me tocaría,
de cómo hemos creado Pocoyó.
De cómo hemos hecho La Familia Telerín.
Vengo a contaros cómo tener razón
no sirve de nada.
O puede no servir de nada si se usa
tan mal como yo la utilicé.
Vengo a contaros cómo teniendo razón,
fui capaz de cargarme una compañía,
de cargarme un montón de
puestos de trabajo,
de fastidiar la relación
con algunos amigos...
Y de arruinarme.
Pero empecemos por donde se debe,
por el principio.
Mirad, a finales de los noventa
trabajábamos en
una de estas consultoras de internet.
Estas en las que al principio
tenías que ir con un traje impecable.
Y luego nos dijeron que los trajes no,
que ya estaban mal vistos.
Teníamos clientes enormes
que nos pagaban muy bien.
Teníamos un proyecto interesante.
Pero no nos llenaba.
No era lo que queríamos hacer.
Así que decidimos abandonarlo.
Decidimos empezar desde cero.
Decidimos que era momento
de hacer aquello que nos apetecía.
Aquello que nos gustaba, que nos motivase.
Bueno, queríamos ser
nuestros propios jefes.
Nuestro razonamiento era muy naif,
era muy de niño pequeño.
No queríamos tener jefes,
queríamos hacerlo solos.
Queríamos hacer lo que nos gustaba.
¿Y qué nos gustaba?
Los videojuegos, la tele, el cine.
Nos gustaban los cómics.
Nos gustaban los dibujos animados.
Porque, si os pregunto, todos seguramente
tendréis unos dibujos animados...
...de vuestra infancia, que de alguna
manera os marcaron.
De alguna manera, dijeron:
"Este es mi dibujo animado favorito".
Este es el mío.
Mazinger Z.
Era la pera. La pera.
Los sábados por la tarde,
no me podía perder Mazinger Z.
Como sabéis, no se podía grabar.
No había VHS.
Dentro de todo ese mundo
que estábamos construyendo...
...de ese afán por ser nuestros jefes...
...de desarrollar lo que
nos apatecía...
...estábamos en la edad en que
empezábamos a tener hijos.
Eran muy pequeños o estaban
a punto de nacer.
Y pensámos:
"¿Por qué no fabricar
los recuerdos de nuestros hijos?".
"¿Por qué no regalarles un contenido?"
"Por qué no regalarles una serie?"
Y bueno, así nació este niño.
Este Pocoyó.
Que no nos dio pocos
quebraderos de cabeza.
Una cosa que aprendimos
es que el trabajo principal
que tiene alguien que tiene una empresa,
alguien que trabaja en un proyecto
de estas características es que tiene
que aprender a resolver problemas.
Nos pasábamos todos el día
resolviendo problemas.
Todo el día.
Es nuestra función principal:
resolver problemas.
El primero al que nos enfrentamos era que
nunca habíamos producido una serie.
No sabíamos producir televisión.
Nunca lo habíamos hecho.
Teníamos un diseño precioso, magnífico.
Pero teníamos un problema.
Y es que no sabíamos ponerle fondos.
No éramos capaces de poner a Pocoyó
en un fondo.
Se empastaba, no funcionaba,
había mucho ruído en pantalla.
Y encima ponerle fondo era más caro.
Así que, sin que se entere
ningún periodista,
lo que hicimos fue hacerle
con fondo blanco.
Podría contaros que fue fruto de
un análisis sesudo,
el diseño blanco puro, la limpieza...
Mentira.
No sabíamos producir con fondos.
Y encima era más caro.
Así que decidimos hacerlo
con fondos blancos.
La verdad es que cuando nació Pocoyó
la respuesta de la gente fue excelente.
A los niños les encantaba,
a los padres les encantaba...
Les encantaba la música, les encantaba
la voz de Stephen Fry en inglés.
En español la de Jose María del Río...
Quiero decir, nos dio muchas alegrías.
Solo le podemos estar agradecidos.
Tanto es así, que fue portada
del Wall Street Journal.
Este pato también nos dio
un montón de problemas.
Pato no era Pato. Era "Ducky".
Queríamos hacer una serie
muy internacional.
Tenía que hablar en inglés, por supuesto.
No tenía sentido que tuviese otro nombre.
El caso es que nuestra asesora educativa,
una británica excelente,
con un conocimiento enorme
de la pedagogía,
de la necesidad y la forma en la que
los niños aprenden...
...nos dijo que no podía llamarse "Ducky"
porque esto no era un pato.
No podía llamarse "Ducky",
teníamos que buscar otro nombre.
No podía llamarse "Ducky".
Ímaginaos, habíamos gastado un dineral
en el registro de marca.
Teníamos los dominios... Todo.
Pero no podía llamarse "Ducky".
Así que en una de las muchas reuniones
de brainstorming buscando una solución
a ese problema, a alguien medio en broma
se le ocurrió decir:
"¿Y por qué no Pato?"
Nos lo tomamos a broma al principio.
Hasta que alguien dijo esas tres palabras
que son capaces de cambiar
la historia de España:
No hay huevos.
[Aplausos]
—[Inglés] Hi, how are you?
—Really good.
—Ya tenemos nombre.
—¿Ah sí?
—Sí.
—[Deletrea en inglés] P a t o.
—¡Oh! ¡Pato!
—Es maravilloso, me encanta.
¡Suena fenomenal!
A los cinco meses vino a cenar a Madrid.
Ya le habíamos mandado los guiones,
ya se estaban grabando voces...
—Por cierto, ¿qué significa Pato?
—"Ducky".
Le encantó eh. Le encantó.
La verdad es que se divirtió esa noche.
Será por el vino.
Pero no vengo a hablaros solo de esto.
Este fue el punto de partida.
La verdad es que hacia finales de 2007,
principios de 2008...
...ya dejamos la compañía.
Dejamos Zinkia. Consideraron que ya no
hacía falta capacidad creativa, talento.
Que se requerían otro tipo de cosas.
No nos poníamos de acuerdo
y decidimos irnos.
Otro problema.
Ímaginaos la congoja. Dejas a tu hijo.
Es como un desgarro. Duele.
La respuesta fue que
nos pusimos a trabajar.
En dos meses teníamos una compañía nueva.
En seis, una propiedad nueva.
Antes de finales de año
la habíamos financiado
y ya habíamos empezado la producción.
El resultado. Bueno. Excelente.
Éramos felices.
Habíamos conseguido reinventarnos.
Habíamos sacado adelante
un proyecto nuevo.
Bailábamos la conga.
Nos lo pasábamos realmente bien.
Las ideas fluian. Hicimos en dos años
lo que no habíamos hecho nunca.
Hicimos tres conceptos,
tres proyectos nuevos.
De verdad, no cabíamos
en nosotros de gozo.
Teníamos nuestra compañía otra vez,
estábamos en el mercado.
Pero en 2012 algo cambió.
Algo se torció.
Esa crisis que había venido ya
desde finales de 2007 contagianto todo...
Nos llegó. Nos llegó la crisis.
Cuando arrancábamos
la segunda temporada de la serie
uno de nuestros coproductores nos dijo
que no podía seguir invirtiendo.
No solo eso. No podía seguir
emitiendo la serie.
Cosas sobre amortizaciones que la gente
que hable en Excel entenderá.
A mí me costaba.
Si la televisión no podía emitir,
el juguetero no podía vender el juguete.
Y el licenciatario no podía
vender sus productos como los libros.
Es decir, se habían producido
una serie de circunstancias en cadena
que estaban empezando a asfixiar
a la compañía.
En paralelo, el otro coproductor portugués
con la troica en su país, a él
le retiraron sus fondos
y nos quedamos sin dinero.
De la noche a la mañana.
En tres meses teníamos
menos dos millones de euros en la caja.
No éramos capaces de hacer frente a los
pagos de los salarios, a los provedores...
Estábamos absolutamente asfixiados.
Esto no podía ser.
Teníamos contratos firmados.
Teníamos cosas hechas.
Teníamos la razón de nuestro lado.
Tenía razón. Tenía razón.
Cogí la razón y me la puse por montera.
Y con la razón me fui a visitar a
nuestros socios.
Les dije que no podían hacernos esto.
Fijáos en lo que tenemos detrás.
Tengo razón.
Y me decían: "Sí, tienes razón, pero
no podemos hacer nada".
"Son las circunstancias".
Así que yo me iba con mi razón
y a veces la dejaba en el aparador
de mi casa y la miraba y decía:
"Pero si tengo razón, no puede ser.
Esto se arreglará seguro. Tengo razón".
Jugaba con la razón.
Jugaba al fútbol con la razón.
Si tienes razón las cosas
se tienen que arreglar...
La razón empezó a crecer entre mis manos.
Empezó a crecer, y crecer y crecer.
Era como un tumor. Tener razón empezó a
contagiarme. A llenarme.
A llenarme de ira.
Tenía razón, me la daban,
pero no hacíamos nada.
No estábamos solucionando el problema.
Tenía a toda esa gente detrás,
no podíamos parar.
¿Qué iba a hacer?
La razón seguía creciendo y yo con ella.
Y mi enfado.
Cogí la razón y la utilicé como
arma arrojadiza.
Empecé a pelearme porque tenía razón.
No estaba buscando resolver los problemas,
como en esos fondos blancos
o el nombre de Pato.
Lo que estaba haciendo
era atizar con la razón.
Estaba golpeando con la razón.
Estaba tratando de convercer al mundo
a golpes de que tenían que hacerme caso.
Y cumplir con lo que
se habían comprometido.
Era un error.
Fue un error.
Eso nos condujo a perder la compañía,
perdimos amigos, coproductores...
No conseguí nada.
La razón solo me sirvió para destruir
lo que habíamos construido
en un montón de tiempo.
Porque la razón por sí sola
no sirve de nada.
Si no tenemos las herramientas adecuadas,
si no las utilizamos con criterio...
...si no somos capaces de usar la razón
como un medio para resolver problemas.
No sirve de nada.
Y me costó mucho tiempo entenderlo.
Cuando me di cuenta teníamos un erial.
Un erial.
Mirad, la razón bien utilizada es
un arma poderosa.
Pero entre tener razón
y resolver un problema
he aprendido que es mucho mejor
resolver un problema.
Y es lo que procuro. Ha sido
mi aprendizaje después de cinco años.
De meterme en este lío.
Y quizá, como la vida no deja de darte
oportunidades...
...al cabo de diez años me he vuelto
a encontrar con este niño azul.
Y ahora lo único que quiero.
A lo único que aspiro
es a dedicarme a resolver problemas.
Y no a tener razón.
[Aplausos]
Gracias.